PlayStation experience is happening and
the opening showcase was overflowing
with new trailers and announcements I'm
Tony and this game spot news update
breaks down the best of them the
showcase kicked off with some uncharted
4 DLC and that's where I'm gonna start
to the Lost Legacy is a standalone game
starring Chloe freezer in Nadine naughty
dog says it's best described as a quote
news story chapter speaking of new
chapters marvel vs capcom is coming back
with marvel vs capcom infinite the debut
trailer showed megaman andreu teaming up
to battle Iron Man and Captain Marvel
you should expect plenty more characters
on the roster when infinite drops in
2017 and if you want even more
characters street fighter 5 is getting a
second season of new fighters there are
six of them on the way and the first one
is fan favorite Akuma while we're
talking about fan favorites we also got
a look at the crash bandicoot remakes
the first three games are being packaged
as the insane trilogy but they're not
the only playstation classics coming
back wipeout HD HD fury and 2048 are
also being remastered for ps4 as the
omega collection and we're getting ps4
remakes of the beloved Parappa the
rapper patapon and loco roco in terms of
sequels knack to is totally happening
and this time it'll have co-op but
perhaps the biggest sequel and trailer
of the whole showcase was the last of us
part 2 the game is in its very early
stages of development but we still gotta
look at grown-up Ellie and an older Joel
PlayStation experience runs through
sunday december forth so expect even
more news to trickle out these stories
were only the tip of sony's iceberg what
announcements were your favorite let me
know in the comments or on twitter at
chain-gun hope and for all the latest on
playstation you're already in the right
place
[Music]